all right let's start with uh francis i
mean uh
his his speed and power you just came he
was very
kind of like wild yeah just coming
swinging the problem is if you if you
can't weather that and you make one he
just touched to the end of his chin
and you're honestly he landed pretty
yeah you're going to sleep i mean i
i it's weird to me his coaches were
probably like dude we trained 12 weeks
for i mean we don't
just run sprints if that's what you're
going to do yeah like we don't need to
do all this technical training like
these coaches are very technical
are they really yeah yeah i came with a
great game plan i'm sure like
hey dude if you're just gonna blitz the
[ __ ] at him like canyon style
we don't need that right just you don't
need coaches just get in shape and do
that yeah
it really did look like it was just a
blitz it looked like almost like a panic
of just coming in
i think that's wrong i don't think it's
a panic i think it was zero respect for
rose and strike and i was like oh you're
gonna call me out
i'm gonna beat the [ __ ] out of it is
that what it was yeah someone just kind
of
panicked at all right yeah i think he
was like he can't do [ __ ]
i think he wasn't scared of his power
anything and just total disrespect i was
like
cool story his speed at his size is what
what astonishes me explosive yeah he's
so explosive terrible technique footwork
footwork was off chin in there i
literally think he was like
this guy can't knock me out yeah train
through he's built and probably as
athletic if he were if he was he's from
this country if he grew up in this
country
easy i'll say it if he grew up in this
country he looks like the kind of guy
who'd probably be in the nfl
as a he looks like he's defensive ends
6-4 265 yeah i mean he looks like he's
got
he looks like a an nfl player he looks
like he's
you know like one of those freaks he's a
freak
look at him you know there you go he's
260 with that build
and 95. i would be willing to bet a lot
of money that
that's how he's built i don't believe
he's doing any kind of drugs no
and i think the same thing with usman
usman is just these people
he's just [ __ ] that muscular
some people are just freaks now i'd like
to see him run a 40
before we put him in the nfl as a first
round draft pick again i think some of
that
is a lifetime of running practice you
you know you can't be born you're born
faster you're born slow there's no you
can't really get you know
but there's techniques yeah but yeah i i
feel like he has
speed i really do and what's this guy's
background
because he's he looks great
wow he got caught
he didn't get caught he got knocked out
they're just playing that exchange game
he just got [ __ ]
what do you do get what do you do about
that don't go straight back you you're
left to the right he went
straight back just like with his back i
think he was so explosive with his
background
you know he should be able to go left to
right but he negate the right hand but
he just went straight and he caught
against the cage and you have nowhere to
go
wow yeah
man yeah hopefully he fights for a title
i think n and ghana was one of those
really dangerous guys
uh obviously in in um
in the beginning of the fight and if you
can weather that and wrestle with him
i would imagine the next guy that fights
him if i'm his coach if i'm the coach of
the next guy advice might go
listen to me right now dc i don't care
you just double leg them okay you get
them on the back and you double leg
man tough to get him down yeah he's been
working wrestling like a [ __ ]
he's gonna be tough
he's very tough he's gonna be your world
champ no doubt you think so 100
you think he beats uh he puts everybody
to sleep
who's in front of him steve adc yeah i
think they're going to fight and then
probably both retire and then
maybe with jon jones there's francis for
the interim you know the vacant bet
that's scary what's your call on that oh
my god think about
god i'm gonna tell you it right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh okay what's gonna
happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[ __ ] disrespect